Perez Musharraf was living in exile for
years fighting to clear his name
the former Pakistani president was
charged in connection with the 2007
assassination of former prime minister
Benazir Bhutto he was also sentenced to
death after being found guilty of
treason before a court in Pakistan
overturned it in 2020 the head of the
military had seized power in a bloodless
coup in 1999 and served as president
from 2001 until 2008.
after the 9 11 attacks Musharraf aligned
himself with the so-called war on terror
General is under American pressure
he is this is not a war against
terrorism this is a war against Islam he
also supported the war in Afghanistan he
tried to balance relations with the U.S
and tribal leaders Musharraf later said
the United States threatened to bomb
Pakistan if he didn't commit to fighting
Al-Qaeda
was criticized for failing to improve
the economy at home and meant ties with
India that's despite a high profile
visit to Agra where many had hoped it
would lead to better relations
firing Pakistan's Chief Justice in 2007
proved to be his fatal political move
it led to Street protests
I rest my future in the hands of the
nation and the people let them be the
judges
family the man who survived multiple
assassination attempts was forced to
resign a year later
he lived in exile for a while but the
lure of power was too attractive he
tried to Stage a political comeback in
2013.
I was thinking the government would call
me back and would say save Pakistan but
that did not happen today my nation
ordered me to come back I came back put
in my life in danger to save Pakistan
instead he was arrested and charged with
murdering Benazir Bhutto the first woman
democratically elected in a Muslim
majority country
the government allowed Musharraf to
leave in 2016 to seek medical treatment
for a serious illness
General musharov though had always
denied wrongdoing and maintained the
case against him was politically
motivated
let's ring in now Al jazeera's Kamal
Haider in Islamabad foreign
had been living in Dubai since 2016.
what are the initial reactions first in
Pakistan to news of his death
well most of Pakistan was marking
Kashmir day-to-day so the news of course
coming on Kashmir day there's a somber
mode obviously this is a man with a
mixed Legacy there are supporters who
will tell you that he did great services
for this country however are since going
into a self-imported Exile after he was
sentenced for treason he was suffering
from a rare disease and that of course
was the cause of his death also now
we're told that his family members are
meeting to discuss whether the body will
be brought back to Pakistan there's been
message or messages of condolences from
The Joint Chiefs of the military that's
the Air Force the Navy the army of gods
has done a lot for the military forces
when he was in power so the news of
course coming again as sad news for a
country that destroy struggling under an
economic crisis and also hit by a wave
of Terror attacks Kamali talked about
Ibrahim most for
well one thing that he was the man who
ushered a revolution in the Pakistani
Electronic media by privatizing by
allowing several channels to come on air
and to be able to have critical debates
so that of course also proved to be his
downfall it was the genie he let out of
the bottle but could not put back also
the fact that he did a lot for not just
the military but also to help improve
Pakistan's image overseas to build uh
important infrastructure his economic
contributions relatively when you
compare where other leaders was
relatively better and also because of
the fact the United States wanted
Pakistan to be a ski launching pad for
its operations in Afghanistan after the
September 11th attacks that was an
unpopular difficult decision for General
Musharraf to make because the people of
Pakistan did not want to get involved in
that war so indeed there will be critics
who will criticize him and of course he
had his own supporters but although he
tried to make a political comeback by
launching his own party the health
condition that he was in was something
that he could not continue and of course
today Pakistani is receiving yet another
sad news that one of their former
leaders a controversial one no doubt is
no more thank you for that Kamal Haider
live in islamabads